allen masc hat es schon wieder getan in
rekordzeit hat er jetzt den prototypen
des mars raumschiffes starship kay one
vorgestellt und die ersten hopping tests
eines kleinen vorläufer sind auch schon
vielversprechend gelaufen er liegt damit
vor dem zeitplan klicks um science und
fiction gibt's täglich faszinierendes 1
videos abonniert den kanal und activity
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen was sind das
wieder für bilder bilder wie ein blick
in die zukunft wie schon die parallele
landung der beiden booster der falcon
heavy oder der tesla im orbit der erde
musk lasst uns wirklich in die zukunft
schauen wir auch jetzt am wochenende und
das ist nur die spitze der kompletten
rakete das raumschiff in dem bis zu 100
menschen zum mond oder zum mars reisen
können wir hatten ja schon darüber
berichtet starship ist knapp 55 meter
hoch und soll auf der rakete namens
superheavy in den weltraum fliegen dass
raptor triebwerk das starship und
superheavy antreibt wurde erst anfang
des jahres im februar 2009 10 getestet
zwei sekunden lang dauerte das ganze
das raptor triebwerk ist größer als das
merlin triebwerk das bisher genutzt wird
und liefert so den doppelten schub
anders als bei merlin werden auch nicht
kerosin und flüssiger sauerstoff sondern
flüssiges methan und flüssiger
sauerstoff eingesetzt da schämt soll von
7 raptor triebwerken ins all befördert
werden die trägerrakete superheavy von
31 die konstruktion von star schieben
ist ganz besonders anders als
ursprünglich geplant wird es nicht aus
carbonfaser mischung gebaut sondern aus
edelstahl regierung musk zufolge soll
diese umstellung einen raschen und
kostengünstigen bau möglich machen doch
von der atlas -rakete wissen wir dass
auch stahl probleme machen kann diese
waren nämlich sehr schwer und brach so
zusammen zumindest sind die außenhaut
und ziemlich beeindruckend aus eine
hochglanz politur soll als eine art cool
faktor wirken und die entstehende hitze
reflektierten marktmacht ist sich sicher
dass stahl das bessere material für
hoeneß sei leichter und das wegen seines
verhältnisses zwischen stabilität und
gewicht der hohen
temperaturbeständigkeit und es deswegen
geringeren bedarf an hitzeschutz und
wenn ihn zu chance hatten
einen besonderen plan er schätzt dass
starship mit 30.000 577 kilometern pro
stunde durch die mars bzw erdatmosphäre
eintreten könnte dabei sei die
unterseite seines raumschiffes vor allem
beim eintritt in die erdatmosphäre einer
unfassbaren temperatur von 1100 grad
celsius ausgeliefert und tatsächlich ist
das heiß genug um die staatsregierung zu
zerstören und so sieht maske ja
keineswegs tausende keramikfliesen wie
sie etwa von der nasa eingesetzt werden
stattdessen setzt space extra auf
treibstoff pakete durch winzige löcher
bluten beziehungsweise schwitzen zu
lassen dabei entsteht eine flüssige
schicht die zu einer abkühlung führen
würde heißt also im klartext der raketen
körper würde sich bei der landung selbst
abkühlen und zwar mit flüssig brennstoff
max stellt sich eine art edelstahl
hitzeschild vor dass somit nicht nur für
abkühlung sorgt sondern zudem auch noch
die stahlkarosserie stützt ein stückweit
kammern diese art von kühlung mit der
kühlung von säugetieren vergleichen der
schweiß wird aus den poren ausgestoßen
um eine zu hohe körpertemperatur
entgegenzuwirken
doch auch in der raumfahrt ist dieses
konzept nichts neues schon die nase hat
damit vor jahrzehnten experimentiert und
hier hat sich des öfteren gezeigt dass
es probleme geben kann und zwar mit
löchern im hitzeschild die blockiert und
verstopft sind
ein ausweg könnte es beispielsweise sein
methan als kühlmittel zu verwenden oder
deutlich mehr poren anzubringen und
methan wird ja auch der treibstoff
zusammen mit dem flüssigen sauerstoff
sein der damit bereits an bord ist
luftfahrt expertinnen und experten
bezweifeln allerdings ob diese idee von
mas tatsächlich umzusetzen ist denn
nicht nur der 1
und singen flug sondern auch die landung
bedeutet eine riesige herausforderung
manche experten und experten zufolge ist
die landung eines raumschiffes auf dem
mars etwa 100 mal schwieriger als die
mars landung eines auto großen roboters
und selbst da geht ja immer mal wieder
etwas schief so oder so kommt mit diesem
raumschiff die besiedlung von planeten
in unserem sonnensystem in greifbarer
nähe und damit auch komplett neue
perspektiven der forschung was können
wir alles herausfinden wenn wir nicht
nur unbemannt oder mit astronauten und
astronautinnen lediglich stippvisiten
machen können new cars will ihnen macht
den mars bombardieren anklicken
anschauen und astor comics
tv abonnieren hammer kanal bis dann
bleibt dran